[Music]
when it comes to data analysis there are
numerous options each using a different
complex combination of tools and
approaches it's nearly impossible for
data professionals to agree to one
platform where they can all effectively
understand and utilize their data a
keyword IBM analytics engine provides a
single environment capable of handling
workloads at scale for data scientists
data engineers and app developers this
new service which combines open source
Apache Hadoop and Apache spark service
enables application developers and data
professionals to develop and deploy
advanced analytics applications in
minutes in order to provide scalability
resiliency and flexibility IBM analytics
engine separates compute and storage
thus eliminating any lingering fears of
data loss in cases of cluster failure
this would make it possible to use
clusters only when running a job as part
of the Watson Data Platform analytics
engine works effortlessly with IBM Cloud
object storage and other data services
like data science experience and data
catalog this integration means a
simplified streamlined user experience
free from a cumbersome coding
requirements of integrating unfamiliar
services analytics engine clusters can
be spun up directly in IBM cloud saving
time and money by providing a new common
engine for data analysis data
professionals are better able to
understand data and collaborate
efficiently on advanced analytics
applications IBM analytics engine
delivers analytics innovation reliable
operations and superior user experience
on cloud
register for a free trial today
[Music]